normally on fridays we speak with our
friend mercedes martinez from mix 941 in
las vegas now about what's trending but
this morning uh well she's trending
yeah and i think it's important we've
all been talking about it 20 years on on
saturday tomorrow since 9 11 and so many
people have personal stories about that
and mercedes you yourself have a really
compelling story that hits home
yeah thanks guys good morning i
put out a tweet last night just because
i was talking to my mother about the
anniversary of september 11th and on
september 11th um 2001 my dad actually
caught a flight in ohio to fly home to
denver and he was their own business he
was anxious to get home to see his
family and shortly after takeoff the
pilot came on the loudspeaker and said
that their flight was being grounded
there was some sort of a security breach
and they had to land at the nearest
airport and that nearest airport was in
omaha so as they are getting ready to
land my dad immediately turned on his
cellular phone just to hopefully get
some sort of connection because he
thought you know what everyone's going
to be running to rent cars to drive home
so i'm going to try and get one but he
actually asked the rental car company if
he could get the biggest ban that they
had
so when they deplaned he ran over there
he got that van and
he ended up going back to the terminal
to find he had seven seats to find seven
people that were able to
get in that van with him and go to
denver he actually found a a cardboard
box next to a trash can grabbed the
sharpie and wrote going to denver and
people people started meeting up with
him and getting in that van with him so
then you posted on twitter this story
and we certainly saw this morning uh you
are trying to find those people right
now it's been years since that obviously
happened you're trying to reach out and
see if you can make some connections
yeah my mom and i were talking about
this and she said that some of those
people actually kept in touch with my
dad for a very long time and he passed
away in 2016 he passed away from brain
cancer and she said we hadn't heard from
them for a very long time and i said did
he ever tell you about the conversations
that were had what that what that drive
was like from omaha and she said he
didn't say a lot about it but they did
keep in touch and i'm really
kind of on a quest to find maybe a
couple of these people i'd like to know
what happened and
we heard his side of the story i'd like
to hear their side of the story and how
that whole experience was for them what
an incredible story for you to have to
remember your father obviously as this
kind-hearted man who was trying to make
a difference in a moment where i think
every single one of us was confused and
scared and worried well mercedes you can
only imagine as your father was driving
uh this van what everybody in there was
talking about as everything was changing
on september 11th here you're on this
long ride from nebraska to denver and i
can only imagine what's what what the
chatter is like what's going through
everyone's minds it's a unique uh
connection between all those people
it absolutely is and and he did mention
that they were listening to a lot of
talk radio but the whole country was in
a state of confusion no one really knew
what was looking what was going around
and uh it was nice because he said that
they all they all bonded they all
reassured each other and i just really
want to know who these people were and
where life has taken them since oh my
gosh okay so the call out folks if you
know someone in denver maybe they've
shared a story that you can make this
connection because that is an
unbreakable bond mercedes thank you for
sharing that wow yeah it's good to see
you
thank you guys for getting the word out
too i really appreciate it take care of
yourself and have a good weekend we'll
see you next week